what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so I was I was looking at like the
idea of flash war and it was you know
things like you know Wally West
remembers everything you know and
they're talking about its kids and so on
and so forth and the more I thought
about that the more I was like you know
May we should do the original flash
rebirth because really this is kind of
like a testing ground something I've
thought about doing is going back and
covering like all the old flash stuff
which is to say everything after crisis
on Infinite Earths between the time that
Wally West first became the new flash
until like this story when Barry Allen
well really when Barry Allen kind of
comes back this story uh flash rebirth
is one of those interesting situations
it's one of those interim stories and
technically speaking Barry Allen
actually returned during the events of
Final Crisis but this is kind of cool
because what this does is it kind of
fills in the gaps right like it kind of
gives us that afterward and the sense
that Grant Morrison brought Barry Allen
back Geoff Johns picked up the slack and
said okay here's what's going on now and
this story is one of those giant retcons
stories basically flows you guys you
don't know what that means
it's a story where geoff johns kind of
takes all this history of the flash and
just sort of reworks it and and kind of
makes it something a little in his own
image but consolidates all that history
down in an easy-to-understand way but
despite him doing that there are some
things we need to know there are some
things we need to be aware of so first
thing I want to talk about here is Barry
Allen for the most part a lot of people
are really really familiar with miry
hounds so this is probably unnecessary
but I'm gonna go ahead and swing for the
fences anyway on this one really this is
like Barry Allen coming back after
what's basically 20 years now again in
truth he kind of like popped up during
the events even going as far back as
Infinite Crisis when he kind of jumped
out of the speedforce crab
superboy-prime and helped to pull him in
when he was being pushed in by like you
know Bart Allen and Wally and and all
those guys but for Barry himself he was
basically he was he's not supposed to be
alive like during the events of crisis
on Infinite Earths when DC was rebooting
and reshuffling everything Marv Wolfman
and George Perez were alike and Barry
Allen's dead out of the picture the new
flash is Wally West and that's how it's
going to be forevermore but Barry Allen
making his return is just kind of a way
to bring back an old-school character
one of you'll have things to bear in
mind here is that a lot of the
references that you're gonna see are
going to be pre-crisis meaning before
crisis on Infinite Earths basically
everything between when Barry Allen
first showed up in 1956 with DC showcase
number four running all the way up to
his death in in crisis on Infinite
Earths there's gonna be small little
things that are referenced here now
if I'm a betting man I'd bet all the
money in my pockets - all the money in
your pockets not the way that DC is
gonna kind of wrap up the rebirth esque
situation which is to say once rebirth
quote-unquote ends and we have like the
official going forward DC landscape
they'll probably give us something akin
to what they did in zero our crisis in
time which is to say once that story was
done DC said all right here's the
timeline
here's when Superman first showed up and
here's when Batman first showed up and I
imagine they're gonna give us that in in
DC rebirth because for people who were
getting into DC rebirth right now and
who are reading it in terms of
understanding what's happening in the
here and now it's pretty easy to follow
but in terms of taking all that
information and consolidating it with
the way things used to be before DC
rebirth in before new 52 it can be
confusing his help a couple of the
things that I also wanted want to run
over here in DC Comics you have to first
speedsters you have the first speedster
in publication history and then you have
the first speedster in the DC Universe
in terms of like the chronology of
publications which is to say when DC
first started making flash comic books
that's Jay Garrick he's the first
speedster DC made in terms of like the
in DC universe history max mercury is
the first speedster which is to say he's
the first person that was able to tap
into the Speed Force the last thing that
I want to bring up here is the nature of
speedsters so originally in DC Comics
and we were getting characters like
Johnny chambers jesse chambers and we
had like like the old-school Jay Garrick
characters truth to tell there was no
real unifying factor among them the only
thing that really unified them was that
they can all run at SuperSpeed and that
was it it wasn't until Mark Waid came
along and started writing the flash
mythos the 90s in the 1990s that we
started getting stories were really like
like the story you know terminal
velocity which basically said there is a
Speed Force and so all the manner in
which these characters gain their powers
it was it didn't just give them
SuperSpeed what it did is it gave them
the ability to tap into the Speed Force
it was a way to kind of unify them all
together now getting into the actual
story itself getting into the actual
events here you know following that what
we basically do is pick up with like a
handful of scientists who are basically
just annihilated by like this kind of
unseen force and of course it starts
arranging chemicals and different things
like that grabbing substances and what a
couple of cops break and basically this
guy just sort of whisks away like he
just kind of disappears and that's
really the end of that I mean a few of
the copter taken out but that's really
about it now following this this goes
into the aftermath of fire
crisis which is to say the flash is back
and it's exactly what we would expect in
a situation like this in the sense that
what Jeff Jones does here is kind of
create a love letter to like the Barry
Allen mythos the kind of things that he
was involved in the other thing that I
want you guys to bear in mind is that it
looks like Geoff Johns is really kind of
ignoring the retold origin of the
Justice Society of America after crisis
on Infinite Earths
and going with like the original origin
what DC did here is is originally the
JSA was basically the Justice League
unlike a different universe what we call
earth - and then you had the Justice
League of America which was earth one
the easiest way to remember that
whichever team that you see Alan Scott
and Jay Garrick which were actually the
two versions you see here talking to
each other whatever a team you see them
on that's the JSA that's earth -
whatever team you see Barry Allen on
that is JLA that's earth one but when DC
had crisis on Infinite Earths
and they got rid of the JSA they were
gone for a long time but when DC brought
them back what they said was that
because there's only one universe now
that the JSA were basically the
superheroes during like World War two
and they retired and like the Justice
League rose to prominence and that's the
order of things now Infinite Crisis came
back and changed that but again because
things were so convoluted and so
confusing post-crisis geoff johns is
kind of going with a simpler explanation
and we know this because we basically
get the flash of two worlds here when
Jay Garrick talks about first meeting
Barry Allen and things like that he
talks about how there was basically a
guy who was in danger and Barry Allen
just kind of showed up out of nowhere
and helped to rescue him that's the
original flash flash of two worlds story
that's when DC first created the
multiverse that you basically at Barry
Allen who accidentally phased into like
earth 2 which was DC's way of bringing
back to 1940 superheroes and then saying
okay now they can all kind of exist at
the same time and crossover which
actually turned out to be a terrible
idea because the continuity got so
confusing but the other half of this is
that we actually pick up with their I'm
sorry with Wally and of course the the
Teen Titans but you also pick up with
giant iris West now the idea here with
giant iris is they were the logical
progression of beer I'm sorry of Wally
West storytelling which is to say when
Mark way to introduce Linda Park when
you had Wally and Linda Park who got
together it made sense they would have
kids somewhere on the line and they did
what ended up happening is we got the
events of Infinite Crisis and we
actually had Wally who basically took
off into the Speed Force er er really
kind of like took off quote/unquote
later on basically left the main DC
universe alongside Linda and iris during
and after the events of Infinite Crisis
and what that did is it allowed DC to
take Bart Allen a version of the flash
in the future who's Barry Allen's
grandson bring him to the modern day and
really kind of like aged him up and then
make him the new flash in a story called
the flash fastest man alive
fans hated it like they absolutely hated
it fans loved loved Bart Allen when he
was impulse they loved it when he was
like a little kid but they did not want
to see him replace Wally West it's one
of the things like we as fans for the
most part are resistant to change when
it comes to changing characters we like
and so because of that with so many fans
who were getting into the flash comics
because of like Justice League the
cartoon show were like the cartoon show
Justice League Unlimited basically they
didn't want to see Wally West change as
a result uh what this does is it
basically gave us a situation where
Geoff Johns brought back Wally West
Linda Park and giant iris but giant iris
had been H Doug and it was a way to
basically roll them back into the mythos
and then have them serve a purpose
give them something more than just like
be kids that Wally takes care of it was
cool it's actually a really really cool
idea giant iris actually have a pretty
cool following when it comes to the
comic book landscape but with Barry
showing up but this is this basically a
big celebration for him it's kind of
funny because again it hits on these
small little moments here and there over
the course of his publication history
when you had him first meet Green
Lantern and like they teamed up for a
little while and this is actually kind
of Geoff Johns really paying homage to
the to the Green Lantern stories one
thing that a lot of people don't know is
that while Green Lantern is really
popular right now there was a time when
Green Lantern was actually so unpopular
that DC made him a backup feature in the
flash for four years so because that
like there's a lot of history that goes
on between these two characters by
virtue of the Green Lantern being a
backup feature in the flash and the fact
that they'd fought together and even
bumped heads because very kind of felt
like Hal Jordan was a little too
reckless when the two of them first met
but again like from there you kind of
pick up with like the black racer
essentially like the the death entity of
the flash mythos just like crash lands
out in the you know and in Fall Ville
Iowa and some kids stumble upon it in
this and it's kind of crazy but for a
for Barry himself looking at this whole
situation around him one thing to bear
in mind is that he's basically missed at
20 years of like everything he's he's
been gone for 20 years and so with him
having missed so much time instead of
like resting on his laurels so to speak
and hanging out at a party he
immediately gets to work and goes back
to be the flash well as soon as this
happens as soon as he starts conducting
himself as a flash he's met by sabotage
but the funny thing about this is that
this is kind of like
veritable tour of like the whole flash
mythos and so we don't really get much
from savitur instead sabotage it's like
I'm free from the speedforce berry
touches him saboteur disintegrates and
that's the end of him and that's kind of
the crazy thing is because that's never
happened before and that's one of the
things that John's kind of toys with is
well maybe like berry coming out of the
Speed Force and basically coming back to
life more or less it has some kind of
like negative effect on the things
around it now within DC Comics Savitt R
was interesting insofar as he had like a
cult following of sorts and what they
would do is actually sacrifice people
and steal their speed and then in turn
like build up their own speed it is kind
of cool to see like these little bits of
history sort of thrown in here and
they're these little tidbits of things
kind of being brought in because it
basically gives us this kind of history
here I mean even with Barry himself he
starts to recall these moments like when
his dad was framed for the death of his
mother and when eobard thawne basically
took out iris and then he snapped the
neck of a year Bart thought this is the
kind of thing that goes into like
pre-crisis stuff because eobard thawne
goes all the way back to like the 1970s
and in fact like barry killed him in one
of the older story so there's a lot of
history there between these two
characters and everything that goes on
but the cool thing about this is that
you basically have Barry who's kind of
poking around trying to figure out
what's happening and Wally basically
travels along with him and that's when
they come across the black racer and
that's where the questions kind of asked
here like what's going on like you know
black racer the last time they saw him
was during the events of Final Crisis
when they basically use the black racer
to run directly in a dark side and then
quote-unquote kill Darkseid and so
that's the question that's being asked
is like what's going on why is the black
racer here now you know why is a black
race are basically dead and then
suddenly you have like this follower of
Avatar who shows up and tries to attack
very much like saboteur he touches her
and she disintegrates and that's when
Wally kind of makes this declaration and
believes he's come to the conclusion
that Barry Allen is like the new black
flash basically he's the new death of
the of the speedsters from here we
actually pick up with Jesse Jesse
Chambers and this is kind of cool
because in this quick little moment we
basically end up getting this situation
where like she sees her dad you know
what he's like Barry keep my daughter
safe you know that kind of a thing and
then it disappears now these little
moments here and there where you see
those things it's actually important and
that's that's gonna be one of the things
that Geoff Johns sort of uses to explain
the way the Speed Force works but from
there you pick up with Bart Allen now in
truth Bart Allen and Barry Allen in a
lot of ways are estranged where Bart
Allen is his grandson
Bart Allen's never really met him before
I never really spent any real measure of
time with Barry really for Bart Allen
the closest thing he has to a
other figure is max mercury but you know
where max mercury I just kind of like
died and been pulled in the speedforce
and that was the end of him Bart Allen
has always wanted him to come back and
that's why Bart Allen's response isn't
necessarily oh hey grandpa are so nice
to see you instead is where's max why is
max not here why did you come back
why couldn't max come back now the other
thing here that Geoff Johns really hits
on it's something called lightning rods
or anchors now this is really just more
of like an emotional state or kind of
like a way to keep someone tethered to
the present and the reason why is
because it's been established in DC
Comics really for a while up until this
story was written that if a speedster
runs too fast they'll get caught in the
Speed Force that you actually can run so
fast that you get yanked into the Speed
Force itself and by and large is it's
usually believed that there's no escape
that once you get pulled in that
somebody has to go in there and get you
out but that almost never happens and so
where you have like Wally West who has a
Linda Park you have Jay Garrick who's
married to Joan and and Barry has iris
what they end up doing is grabbing iris
and bringing her to Barry because what
it means is that very where he's kind of
like this death version of the flash
almost kind of mutated and sort of
twisted around that iris can anchor him
back to reality and bring him back to
where he's supposed to be and that's
initially what happened I mean that
seems to be the case
his powers kind of start going awry the
containment unit explodes and then he
simply just races off you know because
his response is do not let me touch
anybody here because if I do I will kill
them and so he basically races off and
says look I'm just gonna run back into
the Speed Force again what other option
do I have the funny thing about this is
that as he runs alongside Superman who
really kind of says I'm not gonna let
you sacrifice yourself
he starts reverting back to the normal
flash that we're that we're kind of
accustomed to see one of the things that
I want to point out here is this is one
of those stories that fans usually use
when they talk about like who can who's
faster
you know Superman or or Barry like who
would win in a race you know Superman
kind of responds by saying hey look like
we've raced a zillion times and I can
easily keep up with you and Flash's like
well those were for charity Clark so do
not be confused about your place in the
bigger picture and he just like boom
like he leaves them in the dust it's
kind of funny I mean it's the nature of
comics at any point along the line you
could come back and just like any writer
could say well actually Superman is just
as fast as a flash the reason why the
flash outran him there is because
Superman let him but basically what is
up happening is Barry begins to run as
fast as he possibly can and literally
starts to push himself into the Speed
Force the problem with this
is that as he pushes himself into the
speedforce he doesn't end up in the
speedforce that he's familiar with
instead he ends up a word where you
basically have max mercury and Johnny
Chambers is kind of stuck out there and
that's the crazy thing is that where
Barry says look I can grab you guys I
can bring you guys back I can save you
guys the response of match mercury is no
no this is not the Speed Force that
you're used to this is the negative
Speed Force this is the home of eobard
thawne and that's when we get the return
of the reverse-flash now this is cool
because what this does is this is Geoff
Johns kind of like reworking the flash
mythos basically you know reworking the
nature of eobard thawne for years and
years and years eobard thawne was just a
guy who was there who was a like the
mortal enemy of the flash and when I say
mortal enemy of the flash I mean whoever
happened to be the flash at the time
originally it was Barry young after
Barry Allen it was Wally West but
because of the fact of this story is
about Barry what Jeff Jones does is kind
of shift things up now really for a lot
of you guys who were getting into the
flash mythos right now and who are
learning about eobard thawne whether
you're reading older stories whether
you're picking up with some of the more
modern stories this is really where all
that kind of stuff changed back in the
1970s reverse flash was just a guy he
was just an evil version of the flash
when Mark Waid came along the origin was
shifted up and he was basically like a
huge fan of the flash who basically made
himself look exactly like Barry
travelled back to the past only to find
out that he was destined to become
Barry's mortal enemy but it was really
kind of established here that that was
the nature of his character what this
does is it consolidates all those things
down together and it essentially says
that of all the speedsters who were out
there Barry Allen is the one that like
eobard thawne hates the most not only
that what we end up finding out here is
that all this was orchestrated by eobard
thawne because what he's done is he's
essentially like switched Barry into
reverse and what this means is that very
Allen is like channeling the negative
Speed Force that's really what seems to
be going on here is because what Geoff
Johns does is he he kind of like
rectifies a Speed Force itself right
like when Mark Waid originally created
it the idea was that the Speed Force is
just a thing that's there it's just
something speedsters tap into done when
they die they going to go into the Speed
Force and like that's their heaven it
was a way to kind of explain where Barry
Allen had gone you know and different
things like that
what geoff johns does here is he changes
it up in its entirety that were not
initially told that instead all we're
told by eobard thawne is that this is
the the negative Speed Force it's the
opposite of the Speed Force that Barry
Allen taps into that basically the
negative Speed Force has been kin
assistant li generated ever since eobard
thawne first began to run like when he
when he first came back when he got his
powers it was okay I'm just gonna start
generating the negative speed force and
that's gonna be my sole source of power
and that's really kind of Jeff John's
way of saying this is why the eobard
thawne is so powerful because he's the
only one drawing on this essentially
infinite source of energy because of
this what is up happening here with this
kind of huge explanation that's offered
is that it's really kind of like max
mercury basically saying look you're not
like the other speedsters you know
because Barry's idea is I don't know how
to get out of here like you know we have
to find a way to leave max mercury says
you're not a speedster like the rest of
us we tap into the Speed Force but you
create the Speed Force now it's geoff
johns way of basically saying that when
barry allen first became the flash he
started generating the Speed Force well
then the question that came in and
really the question that kind of had to
be answered here is if Barry generated
the Speed Force the Speed Force never
existed before Barry became the flash
then how do you explain the powers of
max mercury and how do you explain the
powers of Jay Garrick if they tap into
the Speed Force and it didn't exist when
they were speedsters and so the
explanation to this is that the Speed
Force permeates all throughout space and
time what this basically meant was that
as Barry ran and the Speed Force began
to generate the Speed Force began to
grow in size and as it grew in size it
permeated all throughout the past and
all throughout the president all
throughout the future and so what it
meant is that Jay Garrick and Max
mercury when they gained their powers
were technically tapping into a source
of power that wouldn't come into
existence until 50 or 60 or even a
hundred years in the case of match
mercury after they first gained their
powers but because the Speed Force
permeates all throughout space and time
they were able to tap into it but that's
the response of max mercury and what
this means is that it's like shining
light in the tunnel because Barry Allen
is powered by the Speed Force so long as
he's powered by that source of energy he
can kind of overtake the negative Speed
Force to a degree or kind of brick his
way out it's like introducing an
antibody into somebody who's sick it's a
way to kind of stem the flow of things
now this is exceedingly important and
the reason why is because what the
negative Speed Force of reverse-flash is
doing is actually eating into the Speed
Force itself it's spreading and possibly
even destroying it and that's why it
matters is because if the Speed Force
were to be completely and totally
destroyed the implication from this
story is that all the features with good
go with it possibly even Barry himself
now the other half of this is that it
reverse-flash himself has actually
traveled directly to the home of like
Linda Park
where giant iris Westar because the idea
is to destroy the life of Barry Allen
now of course beer he's able to make his
way out and faced off against
reverse-flash alongside Jay Garrick and
impulse but it is kind of cool because
you're talking about a person of
extraordinary power and then you have
like these other speedsters who by and
large are kind of doing their best but
what is up happening here is very grabs
max mercury and Yanks him out of the
Speed Force and so it's basically a way
to kind of bring all these speedsters
back now the reason why I think this
matters so much is because what you're
seeing take place here I think is going
to take place in DC rebirth we're gonna
have all these speedsters make their
return potentially during the events of
flash work because if you look at the
flash war story for what it is it's
essentially the events of this flash
rebirth just by a different set of
circumstances but it's cool because
Barry Allen all these different speakers
start start showing up it's kind of a
cool thing here because they're able to
kind of you know put eobard thawne on
that on the defense and while they're
doing that you know while they're able
to sort of you know keep them at bay his
idea is I'm gonna do the one last thing
that I can to take everything from you
like literally I'm gonna run back into
the past and I'm going to make it so you
and iris iris West never meet each other
he starts to like kind of taunting Barry
and that's the nature of eobard thawne
that's one thing to remember what makes
eobard thawne so dangerous is he knows
all the buttons - for Barry Allen and so
that's when at your bar Thawne basically
like pulls back pulls back the curtain
says you know everything you seem like
like what you believe to be your life is
nothing but smoke and mirrors let me
show you how things really are and so he
simply says like every bad thing that's
ever happened to you when you fell and
broke your arm when your house burned
down and fall Vil and you had to move to
Central City when your mother died I did
all of it I literally put your life on a
path to where you would become the flash
I've engineered your entire life and
this is a huge revelation because what
it means is that presumably baryon has
no actual free will his life was
engineered that way he's a pawn and
that's why this was so cool that's why
it was so awesome is because it kind of
transformed eobard thawne from like this
guy who's just an enemy of Barry to a
guy who's like literally controlling his
whole life a guy that's like you know by
the grace of me goes you like just just
so you know Barry like you are who you
are because I allow it like you know I'm
gonna go back in time and kill iris but
like the thing about eobard thawne is
that when it comes to him as a person
he exists in every moment in time so
let's say for example that very Alan
were to kill Ivar Thawne right now
eobard thawne is alive a moment from now
because somewhere
during the timestream he exists in that
point in time and so he's basically like
this immutable indestructible force and
so with him basically showing up with
the intention of like like I mean
literally running through the past
that's kind of the cool thing here is
because you know Jeff Shawn shows you
these small glimpses here and they're
these moments in time were like the path
of iris in the path of Barry began to
kind of converge into a point when they
would meet for the first time they would
hit it off romantically eventually get
married so on and so forth eobard thawne
is running past all these moments but
something that I also want you to notice
is that when they arrive at the point
where like iris was supposed to bump
into Barry Allen and biryani no go goes
on again that powers of the flash a
couple things happened one the lightning
bolt that strikes Barry Allen at the
same time he's dealt with chemicals
that's this that's this fight that goes
on the other thing to remember is that
they're fighting at such astronomical
speeds that what seems to be like you
know of a mass event taking place
it happens in fractions of a second I
mean they're moving so astronomically
fast you're talking about a battle
between wali Barry and you know fighting
against eobard thawne this happening is
so fast that you almost can't really
almost really can't even grasp how fast
is all taking place and we know that
because what you have here is you have
this situation where like the wand of
eobard thawne is kind of like falling
down in front of iris West and that
panel is constantly there like it falls
down a little bit by a little bit by
little bit this massive fight all
happens in the span of that talk but
basically like because it all happens so
fast what this basically means is that
like all these things are happening
essentially this fight with eobard
thawne wally barry running all the way
into the past it's essentially kind of
like creating this circumstance where
like they engineer the meeting of Barry
and iris
that's how Barry got his powers when he
was struck by lightning and doused by
chemicals this is how he became the
flash it's a way to kind of basically
say this is a story that stretches
throughout time in the DC universe and
it's the whole story of the flash itself
but that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end ah it's an
amazing story like I love this story of
the like flash Freiberg it's like the
coolest story of the flash is the way to
kind of like update his origin for the
modern reader you know for people who
want to get into the flash mythos funny
thing about this you get this story you
get a couple stories after and then DC
reboots that's why a lot of people look
at new 52 you and say like it was a
last-minute decision there was it was
basically a napkin idea but let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section about this story I love it I
think
absolutely amazing but uh if you guys
are new here to comment explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]